la cgt demande c'est que seules les
activités réellement essentiel vital
continuer à fonctionner avec bien sûr la
protection des salariés mais pour tout
ce qui n'est pas indispensable puisque
la consigne c'est qu'il faut rester chez
soi pour protéger au maximum
il faut que les entreprises y contribue
également et c'est pas forcément le cas
partout avec des mesures de protection
qui ne sont pas assurés y compris
parfois demandé dans des services
essentiels dans dans la santé le social
houleux où le médico social
nous sommes particulièrement inquiets
pour tout ce qui est de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance par exemple les foyers
d'hébergement et la situation dans les
maisons de retraite qui était déjà
insatisfaisante
il ya quelques mois et qui devient très
critique pour évoquer ce n'était pas
dassin germain en laye vous fait vous
vous dites dans votre communiqué de
presse qu'il y a kylie à sept agents de
cet ehpad qui sont confinés puisque
contaminés du coc vide 19 et qu'il ya eu
14 décès récemment dans cet ehpad
est-ce que vous avez la preuve formelle
d'un lien entre entre la continuer
contamination des salariés et les décès
dans cet ehpad
c'est une situation qu'on a prise
seulement seulement hier et c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué de
communiquer surtout dans des services
comme ça où ils sont déjà en
sous-effectif
mais en tout cas on voit bien les
informations commencent à aider à
diffuser le fait qu'effectivement la
situation dans les maisons de retraite
et pas seulement en france devient
devient critique
on sait que les personnes âgées sont
fragiles elles ont en plus souvent
d'autres pathologies et le personnel
dans les ehpad n'a pas de masque donc
pourquoi la focus de ces mots plus de
matériel pour pour protéger les salariés
du coup les résidents par conséquent
bien sûr on peut on ne peut pas accepter
dans une société comme la nôtre de se
dire ben ils sont âgés tant pis non bien
sûr c'est pas assez pas acceptable et on
doit protéger les salariés
résident toutes les personnes fragiles
notamment dans des structures
d'hébergement